[Music]
as expected sony has finally and
formally announced its new version of
playstation plus which combines
playstation plus and playstation now
into a single offering with additional
more expensive tiers available for those
seeking extra benefits because who among
us doesn't like a little extra benefits
all right nate just pretend for a minute
that i don't really care about any of
that stuff and cut to the chase would
you but now that sony has announced the
key details around its updated version
of playstation plus though more
specifics are expected to be announced
later we're comparing it to microsoft's
xbox game pass to see how the two
popular membership programs in the
console space match up while sony hasn't
officially positioned this as a game
pass competitor the two services will
invariably be compared as the main
subscription offerings to pair with an
xbox or playstation console
the new version of playstation plus
includes three tiers with the essential
category staying the same price as it
has been and the extra and premium
categories carrying higher monthly
quarterly and yearly prices and they
bundle together additional services and
features the essential category costs 10
a month or 60 a year the extra category
costs fifteen dollars a month or a
hundred dollars a year and the premium
category costs eighteen dollars a month
or a hundred and twenty dollars a year
for xbox game pass though there are
three main offerings including pc game
pass xbox game pass and xbox game pass
ultimate both pc and xbox game pass cost
10 a month or about 120 a year meanwhile
xbox game pass ultimate costs 15 a month
or around 180 a year
people subscribe to services because of
what content is available and the real
meat and potatoes of the matter comes
down to what playstation plus and xbox
game pass offer starting with
playstation plus the essential plan
includes all the benefits of the
existing playstation plus subscription
including free games each month
discounts on games and other content
cloud storage for saved games and access
to online multiplayer the extra tier
includes all of that plus a catalog of
up to 400 ps4 and ps5 games to come over
time this library will include
blockbuster hits from playstation
studios and third party publishers the
premium membership meanwhile has all of
that plus up to 340 additional games
including ps3 games delivered via
streaming and quote beloved classic
games from playstation playstation 2 and
psp available over the cloud and via
download premium also includes cloud
streaming support for some playstation 4
games in supported markets where
playstation now is offered on top of
those perks the highest tier of
playstation now will also include time
limited trials a deluxe version of
playstation plus will be available in
markets that do not currently support
cloud streaming and the deluxe offering
will be priced lower than premium
specific pricing will vary by region
deluxe will also include original
playstation playstation 2 and psp games
to download as well as time limited game
trials and other benefits from the
essential and extra tiers also of note
is when the new edition of playstation
plus begins its rollout in june
playstation now will no longer be
offered as a standalone service going
forward it will be bundled with
playstation plus and existing ps now
members will be migrated to playstation
plus premium at no extra monthly cost
for xbox game pass one of the biggest
benefits and among the most significant
differences from playstation plus is
that all first party games and some
third-party titles launch into game pass
on day one in addition to day one new
releases game pass members across
console and pc get access to a growing
library of titles with new ones being
introduced each month with microsoft
recently taking ownership of zenimax
bethesda's games are in the catalog too
and this will also include the big new
release star field later this year and
the elder scrolls 6 later on similarly
at least some of activision's titles are
expected to join the lineup soon when
microsoft's blockbuster deal to buy
activision blizzard goes through as it's
expected to game pass members also get
discounts on games and content as well
as monthly perks like bonuses for halo
infinite additionally game pass ultimate
and pc game pass members automatically
get access to ea play which is ea's own
subscription service that includes big
back catalog games from the star wars
battlefield and mass effect franchises
among others game pass ultimate the most
expensive tierra game pass also includes
xbox live gold which is required for
online play and provides access to its
own library of free games with gold
titles each month as well as the ability
to stream games from the cloud
content is king and both playstation
plus and game pass offer up games galore
to subscribers those who subscribe to
the playstation plus premium tier will
get access to more than 700 games over
time including titles from across
basically all areas of playstation
dating back to the original playstation
these classic era playstation games have
yet to be announced however but sony
promises more details to come the full
list of newer playstation plus games
hasn't been confirmed yet but death
stranding god of war spider-man
spider-man miles morales mortal kombat
11 and returnal will be there at launch
in june with more to come over time this
is in addition to the hundreds of titles
available through playstation now
streaming service not to mention the
monthly free games that playstation plus
subscribers get on xbox game passes
library is stuffed with more than 100
titles already this is not an infinitely
expanding catalog though because games
cycle in and out game pass ultimate
members also receive new waves of
freebies each month via games with gold
as well as a huge catalog of backwards
compatible titles from the og xbox and
xbox 360 at no extra cost
one of the most pronounced differences
between playstation plus and game pass
comes from day one releases xbox game
passes strongest selling point is how
microsoft's own games and some
third-party titles launched directly
into game pass on day one at no extra
cost to members in 2021 this included
high profile blockbusters like halo
infinite and forza horizon 5 among
others in 2022 all xbox players will get
bethesda's big new release starfield as
well as mlb the show 2022 and sniper
elite 5 among others sony's strategy is
significantly different playstation
bosses jim ryan has said that the cycle
of investment that leads to commercial
payoff could be significantly derailed
if sony were to take that approach quote
in terms of putting our own games into
the service or any of our services upon
their release as you well know this is
not a road that we've gone down in the
past and it's not a road that we're
going to go down with this new service
we feel if we were to do that with the
games that we make at playstation
studios that virtuous cycle will be
broken the level of investment that we
need to make in our studios would not be
possible and we think the knock-on
effect of the quality of the games that
we make would not be something that
gamers want we feel like we are in a
good virtuous cycle with the studios
where the investment delivers success
which enables yet more investment which
delivers yet more success we like that
cycle and we think our gamers like that
cycle how many times can one man say
cycle in a single press release but ryan
went on to say that sony is not strictly
committed to this it could turn around
and change its stance at any moment
based on market trends and other factors
quote the way the world is changing so
very quickly at the moment nothing is
forever so i don't want to cast anything
in stone at this stage all i'm talking
to today is the approach we're taking in
the short term the way our publishing
model works right now it doesn't make
any sense but things can change very
quickly in this industry as we all know
and that's all we know about the
differences between xbox game pass and
the new playstation plus but there's
sure to be a ton more to discuss between
now and when playstation plus relaunches
this june so don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss any of that coverage
right here on gamespot until then thanks
for watching
[Music]
you